Și.
Calculatoarele cuantice sunt foarte sensibile la zgomot,
perturbații care provoacă erori
în calculele lor, dar o nouă cercetare arată că
calculatoarele zgomotoase ale IBM egalează metode clasice exacte
și verifică regimurile, depășind metodele clasice sofisticate de
aproximare în ambele regimuri verificabile
și în regimuri neverificabile,
pentru un experiment de simulare dificil.
Cum reușesc asta? Folosesc o tehnică specială
pentru a gestiona zgomotul
în sistemele cuantice — se numește error mitigation.
Cu tehnica de error mitigation
folosită în acest experiment, rulăm calculele
și creștem încet nivelul de zgomot.
Apoi extrapolăm înapoi la rezoluția zero a zgomotului.
Această lucrare ne aduce cu un pas mai aproape de computingul cuantic util
noi